[Music]
foreign
I'm a Solutions engineer at posit I work
with customers to help them turn their
data science work into applications apis
and reports that can be used throughout
their entire organization
and I'm Ryan Johnson I'm a data science
advisor here at positive and this year
we'll be hosting a new workshop at
positcomp called data science workflows
with positive tools using r
for those interested our colleagues Sam
Edwards and gagandeep Singh will be
hosting a companion Workshop that
focuses on python together Ryan and I
have worked with hundreds of data
scientists and data enthusiasts and we
love to see how open source data science
combines with positive professional
tools create powerful workflows that
drive critical data science work
we also enjoy showing teens how our
professional tools like posit connect
can expand their data science
capabilities beyond what they thought
was possible
so here are our top three reasons to
join us for this year's data science
workflows with positools workshops using
our
number one maybe you've already created
shiny apps or reports with our markdown
or quarto and you're publishing those to
posit connect but there are lots of
pieces that can go into these finished
outputs in many ways to streamline and
extend these pieces
we'll talk about ways to automate data
ingestion data validation alerting and
custom notifications to your
stakeholders model deployment model
versioning and much more end to end when
we string all the pieces together you'll
have exposure to powerful workflows and
open source packages that you can take
back to your day-to-day job
number two supercharging your own
workflows is one thing but data science
is often a team effort
during this Workshop you'll get hands-on
experience creating production grade
workloads that enable the sharing of
assets and interoperability across teams
and projects no matter what programming
language is being used
number three we like to keep things fun
and provide everyone in the workshop
with
an engaging environment to ask whatever
questions and explore new data science
workflows we'll also make sure to keep
it relevant and use data that everyone
in the workshop can relate to
those are our top three reasons to join
us for our workshop and we look forward
to seeing you in Chicago this summer